And people who were working in tumor
systems also made the similar
observation that PD-1 is a major target
on the TILs - these tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
that get into the tumor but
cannot kill the tumor -- have very high
levels of PD-1. Then there was a lot of
interest in extending these in vivo
experiments to from mice into non-human
primates and so on. And so on so actually we did a
study with Rama Amara, who's also a
faculty member at Emory Vaccine Center,
and Rama showed that if you give an
infusion of this blocking antibody to
monkeys that were infected with SIV -
SIV stands for Simian Immunodeficiency Virus,
it's a cousin of HIV and basically it's
the HIV virus of monkeys -- and what Rama
and his group showed is that
if you block anti- PD-1 PDL1
interaction non-human primates you get
an increase in the function of the SIV
specific T-cells and a reduction of the
virus in these in these monkeys.
In collaboration we did with with a group
in Ohio with Chris Walker,
we showed the same thing in the HCV
model of chimpanzees. That's really the
only model for HCV that that can be don.
And then Chris showed the same thing
happening in HC- infected chimpanzees.
And as I mentioned, a lot of people
working in tumor models showed the same thing.
And then what has been quite
amazing to see is the very, very
rapid advances that have happened in
terms of clinical trials of PD-1
in cancer patients. This of course is not
our work it's -- we don't work on in
cancer models, we actually never even
worked on in a mouse cancer model, okay,
but the real benefit of PD-1, and the
progress has been quite remarkable,
has happened in the last four three or four years
and these studies have been led by
many major pharmaceutical industries,
three in particular Merck, Bristol-Myers
Squibb and Genentech. These three big
pharmaceutical companies have developed anti PD-1 antibodies
and also anti PDL1 antibodies. I told
you both in effect do the same thing,
they block this inhibitory interaction
and release the brake on the t-cell.
And the results have been quite promising.
PD-1 blockade has been shown to be
effective in both Phase 1 and Phase 2 clinical trials for multiple
different cancers, in particular for
melanoma and for lung cancer.
In particular lung cancer really had hardly
any therapy was there. In terms of
chemotherapy, all of that was really not
not that effective, but depending on
the PD-1 has given promising results
in 15 to 20% of the treated people.
There's not a very large number, but
when you go from basically no survival
to zero percent survival to 15 to 20
percent, there's really quite a dramatic
change in in the treatment of cancer.
And within three or four years of these
human clinical trials starting both
Merck and BMS have a licensed drug.
So PD-1 was licensed last year (2015) for melanoma treatment, actually a year-and-a-half back
for melanoma and last year (2015) also for lung.
So this has been quite remarkable
to see and I give this as an example for
how science should be done.
When we first started this path down this path
many years ago, 25-30 years ago,
really our interest was very simple. We asked
how do you maintain T-cell memory long term?
We were not thinking of cancer
we were not thinking of immune therapy.
That was completely off
our radar, but these
fundamental studies on understanding
T-cell memory led to T-cell exhaustion,
the t-cell exhaustion led to the linking of
PD-1 with T-cell exhaustion and then a
potential therapy for the rescue of
those exhausted cells, and that has very
quickly worked, and the credit
for this goes to the
oncologists who do these clinical trials
and different places, these companies,
to move things ,forward very quickly,
but essentially you now have
drugs which are effective in treating
melanoma and also
in treating lung cancer.